an ohio corner reopened the
investigation into an eight-year-olds
death after he was allegedly bullied in
his final days
Gabriel ia took his own life in January
he was only in the third grade the
public school he attended is expected to
release video today that reportedly
shows his little boy being attacked in
the bathroom
Jamie yuccas looks at how the boy's
mother said the school did not tell her
about this assault Jamie good morning
good morning Gail that bathroom
encounter happened just two days before
Gabriel Tye a committed suicide if the
County Coroner amends his death
certificate he says that she would been
send the case the prosecutor's office if
it's determined violence contributed to
his death an assistant principal at
Carson Elementary School in Cincinnati
found eight year old Gabriel taiier
unconscious inside the boys bathroom on
January 24th he was sent to the nurse's
office then taken home by his mother
that night he was complaining of stomach
pains diagnosed at a hospital as the
stomach flu within 48 hours he hanged
himself in his bedroom prompting an
investigation by Cincinnati Police a
homicide detective said the surveillance
video captured bullying and could even
rise to the level of criminal assault
and noted in his report that after
Gabriel fell to the ground
many students step over point Mach nudge
and kick him she's devastated that her
son's second to last day was so painful
for him Jennifer branch is representing
Gabriel's mom she says the video shows a
student slam him against the bathroom
wall but her client was told by the
school only that her son had fainted if
the school had told mom that your son
was assaulted your son had lost
consciousness for over seven minutes she
would have immediately taken him to the
hospital and had him examined Cincinnati
Public Schools said while we are
concerned about the length of time that
Gabriel lay motionless
and the lack of adult supervision school
administrators followed protocol by
calling the school nurse and say they
asked his mother to pick him up and take
him to the hospital to be checked out
there's going to happening
if nothing is done parents at the school
say the boy's death has prompted some
difficult conversations with their
children it's kind of tough talking to a
five year old about someone she's seen
every day after school not being there
no more and why why did he kill herself
such a tough story CBS News has not seen
the police report or the surveillance
video it's unclear if the student
described in the video is still enrolled
at that school or if any administrators
have faced disciplinary action we did
reach out to Carson Elementary and did
not hear back Nora it's a really
difficult story Jamie thank you